american tantrum The Donald J Trump
predict presidential archives
I love : titles my guess so funny I love
colons I love everything to be in 900 :
[Music]
welcome back to the show it's you up
with Nikki Glaser
oh we've added someone so special to the
room today we have Anthony Knight a
manic already here from the documentary
a presidential documentary the fall of
Donald Trump which premieres tonight at
11 on Comedy Central also with us right
now Ashley Graham should I say it Ashley
Graham welcome to the show thank you for
being here
so he made a beautiful bitch they I'm so
excited to meet you and see you and
you're just as radiant and and lovely in
person as I knew you would be and and
you have a new podcast out you're not
only a model and author and advocate
you're now a podcaster welcome to the
club thank you I mean it's it's kind of
like an intense Club there's a lot of us
there's there's so many podcasts and
everyone goes oh I'm not gonna start a
podcast there's already too many
I'm glad you started one I listen to it
I listen to your first episode and I
think you are a natural
I am so it was such a fun show to listen
to the podcast is called pretty big deal
it is available on iTunes and it came
out of the gate a fully-formed
great show like you feel like the first
time you listen to a show they're
finding their bearings and they're
figuring it out you're just like a
you're a natural host well thank you I
have to give so much credit to my team
because everybody was like okay this is
the structure of a show and then this is
what we do this is how you ask questions
and I was like I don't know what you're
saying structure is so I'm just gonna go
ask a bunch of questions and they were
like are and we just kind of went in
there and was like well that's how you
not do it so this is how you do do it
and then we put a little bit of
structure and now I know what structure
is gotcha like so you had to you had to
mess up you did like test runs and they
say like one test run with my best
friend which was the worst idea ever
because I
knows about her which I didn't know that
I was gonna be a bad idea your best
friend Rachel Rachel Ashley she's a real
estate agent I've known her since I was
17 I was her first client and she was my
first first client whatever and we ended
up living together and now she's just
been my ride-or-die gotcha however I was
like so tell me about that time in 2010
when you did it at it and she was like
bitch if you ask me that ever again on
camera I'm gonna kill you it's better
yes is will we ever see that episode or
no your first episode is with Kim
Kardashian yes
and I went into it list being like what
am I gonna think about this do I even
care I feel like I know everything I
need to know everybody thought that and
you did a fantastic job first of all I
got to know you a lot through it which i
think is important as a host but you
didn't oh overtake the conversation with
drought-like I felt like I knew both of
you by the end of it and I really really
loved her in a way that I didn't before
she was so open and and just real and I
definitely got a few stories that none
of us have heard yes and I thought that
was fantastic but I was such a fangirl
in the beginning I was like and then you
were wearing this with a with this dress
and like this hair and I knew the
hairdresser that did the dadada
afterwards I was like oh my god I'm that
idiot that totally went in but the
interview was it was so much fun we put
our feet up we had a great time yeah you
really brought out a side of her which
was that I had never seen before which
she was I don't she was super
intelligent and just open and was didn't
seem to be trying to impress anybody
like writing about him like she is a
mogul she had she is super intelligent
and she has done so much to get to where
she is and if you think about it from
like where she started to who she is
today like that's not hurt unhurt that's
totally unheard of for someone like that
to have a career and be where she is and
so I praise her every day not like not
like how I praise God
to say like you know she is definitely a
role model when it comes to business
yeah I remember reading about her that
she would really young found a way to
resell boots on eBay I mean before
anyone and she made thousands of dollars
as a high school student just she's a
she's a savvy businesswoman and the
kanye west story that he gave her a
million dollars Mother's Day on Mother's
Day so get this okay so she
how'd it begin because she wanted to
wait somewhat ok altos yes please sorry
there was a brand that wanted to pay him
a million dollars but it all looks kind
of like easy so Kim asked Kanye like do
you think it's okay it's a lot of money
and he was like I'd rather you not and
she's like you know what because I love
you and because you know you're my
husband I'm gonna honor that cut to
Mother's Day a man walks into the
kitchen like I don't know I imagine him
wearing like a bow tie hands her an
envelope and I'm like first of all who
let this manatee go home a little creepy
anyways so hands her an envelope and
it's a million dollar check from Kanye
and then it's also a contract with
equity within easy and so he was like
thank you for always like riding with me
and and and not taking that job here's a
million dollars oh my gosh so many
things about the story I love is that a
million dollars doesn't seem like a lot
to Kim Kardashian but it was she's still
like she was alien dollars a lot of my
contract is the biggest I mean that's
great yeah having that discussion with
your husband and being like I want this
is a lot of money would we have kids we
have a life let's can you let me do this
and he's just like yeah I'd rather you
not and she goes okay yeah fine and she
did it that was like such a bile tea
really cute story you've been with your
husband for eight years we've been
married
that is insane how long she been
together nine we only dated a year what
yeah wait why did that happen so fast
well how did you
there was a few things so we met at
church and then I was like I don't want
a boyfriend
and then he was like well I'm gonna be
your boyfriend and then I fell in love
with him and we waited till we were
married to have sex so that was
something also that kind of sure admit
cuz I wasn't a virgin I knew what I was
missing right oh so you weren't a virgin
but yeah with your husband virgins
why did you guys decide that you both
version my ex-boyfriend was so terrible
and I realized that I was giving so much
of myself up to men who were not does
who were not deserving of me and you
know as a girl who was just dating all
over New York City and I would have like
a boyfriend for three months here
boyfriend for six months there and then
you know and then I got into a really
nasty relationship with a guy I was like
I'm giving it up too soon and I'm not
making these guys work for it I'm not
valuing Who I am
so the next guy I met or the next guy I
date he's not getting any of this until
at least I see a ring on my finger then
I decided it's not even just a ring it's
gotta be like the wedding day so then I
met my husband and sure enough we met in
church what made it a lot easier because
we had the same belief system so I don't
have to convince someone like no trust
me like it's gonna work out but it's
worked out we've been married for eight
years I love this story because it is
validating everything that I am doing
with my life
no just like are you so yet yeah I'm
pretty much you don't get anything until
and it's not even marriage for me but
it's everybody's yourself but it's like
yeah you set your own kind of parameters
but I am NOT I'm done being this girl I
think we grow up as women thinking we've
sold we've been sold this lie about blue
balls and how if a guy doesn't finish
he's gonna hate us and he's gonna be mad
at us and we're gonna be bad women and
it's not men that are necessarily
perpetuating this it's just something
that has gotten to our consciousness as
women that they need if you engage in a
hookup with a guy if he doesn't finish
then there's there's something that you
did something wrong and he might not
call you he might not get you an uber
home or whatever what do you know what
usually if you if you don't finish him
off then he does call you exact
right over and over and you even when
you do finish them they still don't they
do all those things anyway they talk bad
about you behind your band are hunters
they want something to hunt and they
also want something to kind of to be
able to say I got I got her and I did it
the right way and that was something
that I learned in dating every hat at
least half of the assholes in New York
City yeah I I it's my new thing and I
like to hear that you actually waited
till marriage and that you this wasn't a
you had already had sex before you knew
what you were missing out on God knew
that having sex it's like it's also the
person who the person yes you know just
sex alone with someone is not
necessarily an intimate act so like it
has to be with the person that you care
about I think that intimacy 90% of
intimacy is about your you know your
eyes your touch and all the things that
are around that yep just tickle in the
pickle is like this sort of neural sort
of discharge part of it that's totally
different and I mean a lot of discharge
[Laughter]
so how did that go over was he like I'm
down and then you guys got married yeah
yeah yeah okay so you both were just
like this is what we're gonna do yeah he
was down and I don't know it just worked
and then so we made a deal where we
wouldn't sleep over at each other's
homes because we knew if we did yes and
so we did these 24 hour dates where we
would he would pick me up and it would
be in the evening we would spend the
whole night out just like walking around
the city you're going to show is going
you know 24-hour diners then we would
spend the whole day together and it was
like we really got to know each other
and we built this friendship that you
cannot destroy because our trust our
communication is so on point that today
like we can literally just be so blunt
with each other and then just go right
into lovey dovey mode right and by these
24-hour dates you
that you'd work alone in a place in a
bedroom together yeah you would keep me
would sometimes go over to each other's
homes and watch movies or just hang out
like but we weren't you were sleeping in
the same bed because you're right it
will happen if you put yourself in that
position because you get horned up
enough you start making deals with your
somebody making out gonna be weird after
this I'm just gonna do it and I just
can't if you do have sex with someone
too soon girls who are listening it's
okay you can always get that power back
but just try to hold out as long as you
can it's never a bad idea it really is
never a bad idea I've never seen it
backfire on a girl to hold back to not
text first to not hold withhold sex not
not what I mean
it is withholding but you're doing it
for yourself you're not doing it to
punish him I don't think it's
withholding when you haven't already
given it that's a good point you know
what I'm sorry he's a really good point
like it's not yours so shouldn't be
transactional the whole idea should be
you want to weed out the pressuring
toxic masculinity and and sort of
garbage that floats around that's
exactly what happened to me I started
dating guys and they're like what you're
waiting I was like why and then they
would try to hook up with me I'm like no
no no no no no you don't understand and
then they wouldn't call me back and you
weed through the guys who just want to
have sex with you yes it doesn't always
like you saying I'm not gonna have sex
with you it doesn't always work it's not
like that guy is just gonna chase you to
the end of the world no give up they're
not yes and I think there are people who
like to have a lot of sex and they all
like it and all those people meet each
other and they are fine without
commitment I'm saying those folks should
go for it too I don't think there's like
one right way but I think that yeah the
problem is is that or at least hearing
what you're saying is the worst one is
the sort of pressuring and the blue
balls and I come on and I can do it and
the thing that all of any young man
who's passed through their twenties
especially if you grew up in the 70s and
80s that was like the language you were
taught to yeah as a man and like it's a
hard one to undo and you have to undo it
all the men out there undo it I feel
like anyone who went through the DARE
program also was given this aside like
propaganda session
of blue balls and how a guy if you want
to gotta like you he's gotta finish and
I'm still I'm talking to myself here by
the way and hearing you are like an
angel to me right now because I already
look up to you and to hear you say that
that's you're in your relationship has
been eight years strong now which is to
be a young girl married for eight years
is something to celebrate that we got
really when I was 22 that's crazy they
and you can tell the way you speak of
how 30 you can tell how good your
marriage is I mean I'm just and you know
that's the other thing like marriage is
not an easy road like you've got your
your peaks and your valleys and you just
have to remember like are you both
committed are you both gonna stand in
this and I think that the other thing
that people don't talk about is the
highs and lows in marriage and
especially when you're in your when
you're younger and our fifth year was
our hardest year it was because we
didn't get to see each other very much
we fought and we were like what are we
doing why are we married like what's the
whole situation and and I think that if
you remember you made a commitment to
each other and if you both work your
asses off to stay committed to stay
connected to stay communicating there's
nothing that can tear you up unless if
one of you what is the work
give me one specific thing that is worth
is the work so okay you hear that so
when my husband and I have an argument
you know that tension that's still left
in the air where you're like okay we're
over it but we're still pissed at each
other like slamming there's nothing else
to discuss
right but you're both said you're sorry
so we've have this game where we play
the nice game and whoever says let's
play the nice game the other person has
to say something nice about that the
other one so like if I say to Justin
let's play the nice game he has to say
something nice about me and then I just
say something nice about him it cannot
be physical because duh we're both
attracted to each other and it can't be
something that's like surface level like
I really like how you clean the dishes
today okay right so and if you're the
person who doesn't say the nice thing
then you're the first person on the face
of the earth that ever cheated on the
nice game right so then we shun each
other like it's like oh okay you're the
first person ever
so you
you have this game yes so you have to
say sometimes and what that does is it
creates this like loving connection
again because you have it's kind of like
saying affirmations or it's kind of like
saying gratitude to to to your day in
telling this person like you know thank
you for supporting me through this
decision or thank you so much for you
know taking the time to care for me and
whatever it is and it's like okay
alright we're back to square one and
everything's fine yeah nice game I love
that you have you have to be so selfless
when you're married because everything
is about that person and vice versa
you every guard has to go down and that
is something that's very very hard for
people to maintain and dry and I think
the other one is there are things about
your partner that you'll just never will
like yeah certain things xx rule when
you're dating yeah I have it but I can
guess but tell me so if you're dating
someone really truly like it has to be
like 80% of what this person gives that
you are obsessed with the other 20% is
kind of like okay whatever I'll just
deal with it but if it's like 70% is
great and 30% is like oh hell no then
you have to walk away because that learn
is it will get under your skin
experiencing when you go oh the relief
of going I don't have to fix this I'm
not here to change it yeah this is just
a part of them and I just got to accept
it and stop being crazy about it and our
thing we do it can I make a confession
and a confession is when you say
something your feeling and your partner
does not comment respond or anything you
just say it and there you go I'm done
and then no and no thing is because like
being listened to right is the number
one thing that gets lost in the shuffle
yes truly being listened to and you want
to fix because you love and you want to
try to do and so it's a really good way
of going I got to make a confession I'm
really anxious about going to this party
and doing this thing and then you just
let it go because sometimes you just
want to say it it's not about it being
fixed you just want to judge yeah I
when I look back on my relationships and
and I'm kind of like getting back
together with someone I've been with for
off and on for why next years because
I'm realizing the 80/20 thing and I'm
realizing I always broke up cuz of the
20 and that the 80 really I've dated
other people and I have a joke about it
but when I date other people I look at
my ex and I go oh my God he's the best I
can do but because I I feel like I did
really well five years ago and I've
dated since then and I you just compare
and you go no that was pretty great what
am i doing and and he's grown over time
and I've grown over time but something
that I really didn't realize and I think
would help in a marriage or a long-term
relationship is honestly just empathy
and being like they're a different
person than I am
and they're interpreting everything from
a different perspective I don't know why
I never even grasped that until this
year but literally I just every time we
would get in a fight I'm like I only saw
things from why doesn't he see I would
never treat him that way so why is so he
must not love that has to do with
sincere love language yeah I feel like
I'm like doing this like love
counselling I told you you're good have
you guys ever read the five love
languages I I know of it okay we read it
on our honeymoon because we're dorks Wow
and my love language is acts of service
and his is physical touch and time spent
like I could never touch you like maybe
we'll have sex like and it'll be great
but don't like don't comment I don't I
don't want to be touched when I walk in
the door and I don't need to speak to
you he needs both of those things oh
yeah man usually I like touch me touch
yeah and they want to spend time and I'm
like okay if you got everything on the
to-do list on if you book to that
vacation if you did it enough for me
then like oh my god I'll do anything you
want me to show this love languages like
you love the way that you want to be
loved and he's loving you the way he
wants to be loved so you have to
understand each other's love language in
order to love that person like cuz I'm
like well why would you want me why
would you want me to touch you all the
time that's ridiculous because you know
yeah
right and he's like no no no please rub
my head I love it and I'm like oh my god
but now when I rub his head and he like
he does all the things I wanted to do it
people have such as even me and I'm
working on having empathy and I realize
it's something you put yourself in
someone else's shoes but I only have my
shoes and it's so hard to imagine other
shoes but that is one way to do it is to
just read that book on your honeymoon
God have helped it did it really did and
the human psyche is a Congress so in a
way you can understand or empathize in
the sense that there's a part of you
that is more representative let that
other person it's just the captain that
drives the ship the part of you that's
you is the primary part but there's all
these other shades and parts so when
you're interacting with your partner
you're also playing out all of your
family systems all of the different
relationships you've had throughout your
life so it's a it's a complex mess that
sometimes works out and if your hat if
it's really good you get dinner
[Music]
you